hello and welcome to this video the
number is off yes let's put it on for
495 making it correct
I hope I'm playing inside note which
means in time travel
yeah people still stumble into this then
wonder why they're checkmate it quickly
yum this looks like tough to defend for
white I mean threatening to take on g3
already with a kill and h3 is also
threatening with the win h3 Bishop h1 h2
check King G 2 and so on check on h3 is
going to need to made I think White has
already lost him too late too late to
think yeah this is a case where h3 is
going to win
[Music]
yeah this line with the h5 is absolutely
an amazing weapon and blitz chess it is
also pretty strongly tournament if you
get that forward this is a not very
unusual game you get this kind of thing
quite often so what went wrong here the
main issue is that castles is not good
simply because of age five it's funny
that stock fish is like immediately
pointed out here that blank is fine with
age five I mean you have to be a little
bit like to start winning with age five
I mean in practical terms it's very bad
for white to play this but it's not
winning yet but it is very very
dangerous it is in fact better for what
to not cancel and do something else do
something else is actually a wide range
of possible moves in my c4 repertoire on
chasuble and on just when you four we
have a video on that I recommended rugby
one in this position or basically play
anything else and Castle so I found out
when I researched for my English
repertoire that this is a tricky line
for white yeah I think it's best to do
something slow look b1 as I mentioned
what I was recommending or b3 is also
not bad you can also go deforms also
nothing wrong about that the main point
is you delay castling and that means if
black goes for an age 5 approach now
that is not as dangerous for example
what the engine here gives with h3 is
much more of an idea then if you have
Castle already
if we compare cancelling age 5 and now
for example if white goes h3 black is
going to push like that and this is
we are also very tough for white to
defend the rising positions however are
extremely complicated I mean like it
really crazy complicated I also lost my
fair share of games they're usually
within blitz chess I never had it in
tournament tournament game a classical
time control game
I have lost my fair share of blitz games
they're simply for the sake of
complexity
you just blunder sometimes the positions
are often excellent but it's just so
difficult to play that it's kind of
unavoidable that you sometimes make
mistakes and even lose the good
positions after h4 g5 is already very
strong and after takes it's important to
take with the Queen and not play H form
as this is after 95 less than clear you
can try actually to make Gambon's work
like okay this is not working here I
think if I remember correctly but things
like that now are close to working I
mean the attacker is quite strong okay
it doesn't work right here but you see
here with the whole roof down the engine
is just on 1.7 it's not like it's +5 or
something so it doesn't really matter
because you take with the Queen's piece
but it's a lot stronger and now he went
d4 after which h4 is very normal looking
95 is possible on that you simply
retreat with the Queen that's how I
analyzed it back in the day like two
years ago and h4 is next and black has
an attack you can play Bishop d6 Queen
d7 often and cancel long thereafter d
form of h4 is super obvious and I think
this is the the last moment where white
is maybe still someone in the game if
you plays correctly but after efore
Queen h5 it so on it's just lost the end
confirm say - four or something
the threat of now taking on d4 taking on
g3 and h3 is too much at the same time
there should be three h3 it's just
curtains
yeah very recommendable line for black
you will score heavily very sure
thanks for watching